United States
and Ukrainian officials
tell CNN that Russian artillery
is down
as much as 75% from the war time
Officials say
the cuts may be a sign
that prolonged
and brutal
battle has had a significant eff
on Russia's weapons stockpile.
And the Russian forces may be re
and trying to pinpoint
where Ukraine
is going to launch its next
major offensive.
Oren Liebermann
joins us
live from the Pentagon this morn
I think that the big question me
and then what?
It's interesting timing also, Wa
or in that
this comes
as Russia had called for that ce
Absolutely.
A cease fire
the US believes was not intentio
They were or rather not
a real desire
for a stoppage to the fight.
It was
Russian President Vladimir Putin
trying to appeal
to the Christian faithful
and trying to show that it was U
violating the cease fire.
Aside from that
this is an indication
with this dramatic decline
in artillery fire
that something has clearly chang
within the way
Russia is fighting this war.
The question is what
from the wartime
high of 20,000 artillery
rounds per day down to about 500
per day.
Now, Russian military doctrine,
the way
Russia fights its wars, calls
for a barrage of artillery fire
and then essentially ground troo
go in and clean up or mop up wha
So why this significant differen
And that's what the U.S.
is trying to figure out.
According to U.S. officials.
They have talked for a long time
about a shortage in Russian prec
weapons, less
so about the conventional ammo,
just like artillery fire.
Maybe the US officials tell us
this is an indication
that Russia is beginning to run
on its vast stores of artillery
ten months of fighting
and with no end in sight.
Ukrainian officials
say, look, we've
also hit
a number of Russian weapons depo
so this may be making a dent or
they may be regrouping for futur
Russian operations.
Yeah, that's a big concern to al
Thank you very much
for the reporting to the Pentago
U.S.
officials tell CNN
there has been a, quote,
substantive change in the type o
being sent to Ukraine
as the nation closes in on one y
since Russia's invasion.
And this comes days after the U.
announced its largest
military aid package for Ukraine
with new systems
that one official says give you
Ukraine much more capability.
Let's turn to CNN anchor
and chief national security
correspondent Jim Sciutto.
Jim, good morning.
You know all about this.
You were there on the ground
when the invasion happened
almost a year ago now.
Can you explain what is differen
about what they're getting now
in terms of weaponry?
For sure.
I think it's always important to
look at this
not just one weapon system,
but the collection of weapons sy
over time.
And what that tells us
about the battle on the ground.
So let's look at these latest pa
of this package, Bradley
Fighting Vehicles.
I'm going to focus on that in a
More capable surface
to air missile systems
and surface to surface missile s
artillery systems
that are more accurate
and have greater ranges.
That's the collection of things
we've seen recently.
Let's look at Bradley
fighting vehicles in particular,
because these are going now.
It's an armored personnel
carrier, carries
troops into battle,
but it also crucially has a TOW
This is an anti-tank missile
attached to it.
You've heard the reluctance
throughout this war of the U.S.
and its partners to send tanks.
This is not a tank,
but it does have the ability
to attack and destroy Russian ta
And that's important.
It's particularly important
on the battlefield, in the air
in the east.
I'm told by U.S.
officials that this is in respon
to what Ukrainians are asking fo
and the US and its partners
trying to be responsive
to what Ukrainians are asking fo
Can you speak to, Jim,
what these changes reveal
about the battlefield in eastern
It's a couple of things.
So let's look at that battlefiel
One thing that's different about
out there, it's flatter ground,
open ground than we saw.
For instance, around,
say, Kiev in the early stages of
And that that makes you think Wo
War Two tank battles, really, Po
And you got wide open areas here
where you're having an artillery
and you can have these Bradley
fighting vehicles and tanks
really going to open conflict th
The other piece of this
that I'm told, Poppy, is is this
and that is that the U.S.
is concerned
that Russia is going to attempt
to regroup,
launch more aggressive offensive
And they want to get the Ukraini
the equipment
they need now to push back again
I think that's what Bob Gates an
Rice were warning about.
Jim, thanks very much. Thanks